tutti ragazzi e prevede neve solo video
sono fa vj oggi sia un nuovo video di
tra il face quest porca l'aveva fa vj
cola jay staccato la notte possono
picchiare la famiglia non vedere tra
azzeccato tutto tutto tranne la j
[ __ ] vacca ma ci vai a capire che la
j attaccata favi j
mi chiamo lamma stecco di un cazzo è
così i continui a chiamare chuck norris
avviare sti troll face quest per
cortesia non so se ho capito bene vuoi
avviare tall face quest mai pensato a
via troll quest lurida [ __ ] che non
sei altro
[Musica]
o mi chiama se chi cazzo funzionano come
possibile basta insultarla la gente
funziona non c'è via francia vero
bentornato famigie grazie a dio ci
servono tuto schivi giusto non avevo
bisogno per rilassarmi d'accordo
regazzoli continuiamo che ho troppi
questi eravamo rimasti a justin bieber
cosa faccio un movimento play
baby baby 3 mi piace a te schifo che c'è
got simulator lo so posso mettere al
momento proprio il video così va bene
così ma vera veramente cos'è sta roba
che a quanto trash ragazzi quanto 3
miliardi life like a ragazzi le capre le
capre funzionano questo video non piace
a sgarbi siamo su supermario che figo
tanti ragazzi questo sembra un gameplay
che c'è la faccina lui di lui che arride
a posto a trascinarlo volendo dove lo
trascino metto al posto di colore
gameplay è infatti bene adesso puoi
morire tuo zio ha posto suo ok
così se la ride il trofei sabbiamo inter
perfetto livello completa ragazzi questo
so quale scommettete che il labirinto
quello horror
e invece no è frenata non scherza
qualcuno che scoraggiano capito chi ha
uno che cadere allo skate board nullo
che li vanno a fuoco i capelli o che se
scassato internet dispiegate ragazzi il
senso di sto liverno seriamente non ho
capito
dovevo accendere buddha non so per quale
motivo cosa faccio a ok io che devo
picchiare la fa perché sono fatta era
difficile ma si poteva fare sto tra il
quale dall'inizio della partita che si
sta divertendo si fa ma incassa il mago
che sai dynamo devo prendere la il
berretto possono metterti gli ancora che
bello forse più figo così li metto a lui
li metto a lui no di me li ha buttati a
noi messi a un sospetto albero qui c'è
il berretto giustamente sono adesso che
se anche la i baffi la barba quindi
adesso posso farlo io il trucco di magia
perfetto guardi che lo sa indicano una
merda gigante o questa è una posizione
la youtubers perfetto ho anche trovato
la gallina fantastico c'è pure il
telecomando ragazzi posso chiudere il
video perfetto solo io a dover
registrare è un unboxing ma dai mi che
lo scarta jolie pachino che su tron face
quest giustamente c'è anche lo scarto
dei pacchi sa bene scartiamo il parco
ora c'è anche si scarichi a batteria voi
voi scherzate ma c'è una volta che l'ho
dovuto fare davvero sta cosa dovevo fare
il video prima che si scarica sua
batteria anni anni passati a scartare
pacchi non sono serviti anche a soraga
pacchi di cartone non pensate ma un
bastone per i self c'è un bastone per il
magico mio perché ha quindi adesso lo
registro col telefono perché il telefono
giustamente dura di più della
videocamera ovvio fantastico sempre
comunque meglio di alcuni pacchi capro
io è perché il prossimo livello ragazzi
sta diventando sempre più un senso non
mi aspettavo di meglio comunque son
prank sono convintissimo mi spunta fuori
il cavallo jungle style
[Musica]
fantastico a parte il tipo che esce
fuori dall ascensore che dovevo fare
adesso
ma perché è vero che l'indiano tanto a
questo cavallo per prestarsi a queste
cose
devo fare qualcosa che non ho capito
tipo andare il piano lo cambia asilo
cambia piano dove vanno a casa e vabbè
adesso mi sono della spesa a chi c'è la
nascente adesso lady gaga a nessuno
perfetto ed è contento nel senso che chi
non vorrebbe che nell'ascensore ci fosse
psy io lo vorrei tutti i giorni fino a
me questo chi cazzo dei tempi zerial
oggi del meteo del meteo giustamente ata
vorrei bonus che sarà una cosa
vecchissima possano la voce triple
ramble addirittura quadruplo renfro tra
21 orgasmo quest'uomo dio
ecco infatti lo sapevo io vorrei che la
cazzo ripa che piange sarebbe bellissimo
una patata viola quest'anno patata e non
gino strada non ce la faccio a toccarlo
mi fa schifo una mucca un po che cazzo
di video è qui che le aveva spiegato ma
non l'ho capita questa ragazza che lo
dico subito quando non riesco a fare una
roba raga perché devo trascinare le cose
sempre
questo che fa la country music dello
spazio mi mancava senti e sheeran
certo era tuo amico quello ad essere
così triste dai che se n'è andato la
compagnia difficile frate ascolta azione
scarica tra slightly se ti piace
lusitano sto continuando a suonare
divertiti con fa vj sheeran di temi
quanto può essere mai bella una canzone
così ecc
[Musica]
cornice cosa devo schiacciare perché li
mortacci mia sono stanno ora qua oddio
l'ho preso ma come brava poverino
qualcosa ma pure alieno e cosa ho fatto
ho trascinato il dito comunque la
soluzione è sempre quella se trascini
dita in cui spiace per l'amor di dio era
carino bene che cos'è starò questo è un
altro video gay è un gameplay tutti che
tutti gameplay soraga tanto già so che
dovrò trascinare inutile che che
proviamo ad ioan non ho questo ed
intelligenza ragazzi miglia di
intelligenza io siamo a posto
cosa devo fare ragazzi allora in teoria
se la mia ipotesi è giusta quando
l'acqua esce dal tubo arriva all'altro
tubo ci apriva quindi io schiaccio
ovviamente non funziona incalza allora
dimmi col quale il problema a minchia
non ci ho pensato ragazzo invaso un
genio si sta roba ad opzionare che non
posso dire quali abbiamo un gatto
vestito con lo avverte globali
[Musica]
sicuramente ho vinto o cazzo bisogno
c'era di strano il suo livello canzone
sempre più orecchiabile di justin bieber
con la capra per l'amore di dio va beh
qualcuno viene trovato senso però c'è il
troll dj trolley e la trovata del secolo
ti saresti tu trolling harris faccio
scratch fogli magia magia jia jia tratta
sono tutte volpi the fox guarda stefan
sei ragazzi il tipo con la effe con la
maglia di fa vj c'è un ballo emozionante
giuro calcio è fatto schiacciare come lo
fa con il nord
oddio è uscito un altro tasto a caso ci
sarebbe bello web e cloud 6
non so tra questo e troll instyle quale
più bella però mio dio se la giocano ed
è che al ragazzi ha concluso piccole
livelli me ne mancano ancora 10 in
teoria faccio solo al minigioco regate
mi manca 25 punti per sbloccarmi i
prossimi livelli quindi miniera troll
non ho capito cosa dovrebbe essere ma io
devo trovare le ho trovato un trono a in
base a quante cose trovo mi dai punti
fantastico vabbè dai preston cosa di
fango che sfiga vuoi spiegarvi perché la
pietra dovrebbe ridere come come come
fisicamente potrebbe mai essere
possibile spiega tema ok quindi qualcuno
a cagato sopra un cadavere
qualcuno ha messo un tubo arrugginito
vicino un cadavere sul quale hanno
pagato del tesoro fantastico altro
tesoro e che cazzo non c'è niente ma
vermi è bello fantastica medaglia sono
arrivato a 250 quindi posso sbloccarmi
livelli successivi ma voleva che suoli
prioni concludere do un'occhiata
stavo scherzando non lo voglio più
vedere gli ultimi livelli vi farò nel
prossimo episodio ragazzi per ora spock
e video vi sia piaciuto come al solito
seguito è piaciuto mangiando davanti io
c'ho già mi piace cosa sento seguito è
piaciuto sono argomento è un mi piace
adesso va bene anche la faceva riferisco
che con il video tratta d'estizione io
continua non trovarci un senso a questa
roba
però
ormai va bene saras e orsi discrete cv
da un prossimo video belle ragazze